eric fetty when you're a guy like him
who has the sinker slider where does it
all begin it begins with fastball
command if he can be effective with the
fastball early finish him off with the
slider he should get rolling bryce is
getting a warm welcome harper does have
19 hits in his last 13 games
and a high fly ball to deep right center
field it is gone
into the second deck and then out
bryce harper a solo home run as seventh
of the year and the phillies take a
one-nothing lead i'll tell you some of
his are not cheap this year
man it's a beautiful swing but again
it's all about balance with bryce if
bryce stays on balance
he can do a lot of damage but when he
gets off balance and starts leaning
backwards when uh but when his balance
is good tom
he can do some serious damage bryce
harper with his seventh home run of the
season a majestic blast to right center
and the phillies have the one to nothing
lead they're better to see them live
aren't they scott oh my goodness chase
anderson putting the initials of his dad
and his grandparents in the back of the
mound before he gets ready to fire well
here's belle former pittsburgh pirate in
his first year in washington
swagga to miss
well he got him with the cutter
his cutters had a very different it's a
very different pitch recently it's
almost like it's just floating in the
middle of yeah and that's he's lucky he
got a guy hit 140 on that pitch he's
walked his first time up with the count
three and two and two outs runners go
again pitch his hit out towards center
field that's going to drop in for basin
harper scores easily miller's on his way
to third he'll be held there rbi single
for hoskins his 19th of the year and
it's two-nothing phillies
well that'll help the old disposition
right there tom and look he didn't hit
it square hit it off the end of the bat
you look like a cutter by fetty you see
reese right there just hit that ball off
the end of the bat
but
he hit it where they don't play tom
look at that just perfectly placed josh
harrison no chance robles no chance
bryce ronnie scored
eric fetty gets back to work herrera
will lead off
line drive out to right center field
that's going to be in for an extra base
hit it's going to one hop the scoreboard
herrera is on his way to second and
he'll get there so lead off double his
first double well that'll bring up
andrew mccutchen
fly ball center field
should be keeping up the score herrera
schwarber catches it gets behind it
launches the throw to the plate it's way
off line sacrifice fly for kutch
his 16th rbi of the year the phillies
are out top three nothing that's a fine
execution by the fields tom a little
double sacrifice bunt by chase anderson
which we saw his first at-bat he wasn't
that adept at popping it up and then
andrew just gets something out over the
plate that he can hit into the outfield
commanding three-run lead
he's up three-nothing bottom of the
fifth inning josh harrison first time up
two balls two strikes to harrison
swing and a miss man did he tie him up
with that change up five strikeouts for
anderson might have been glad he didn't
hit that one seriously he might have hit
his foot that time gotta spin on that up
that that ball had a lot of move that's
one of the
changeups i've seen chase anderson throw
and had that much movement on
fly ball left center field oh double
herrera is out there he's couple steps
from the track and he makes the catch
another solid inning for chase anderson
who's not allowed to hit since the first
we've played five we're on to the sixth
philly's leading three nothing bases
loaded one out top of the sixth will
harris
will bring his cutter curveball
combination to the mound
fastball in was the target fastball over
the plate is the result
and mccutchen could not pull the trigger
on the cutter two down yeah mccutcheon
was looking away here looking for that
breaking ball or that cutter away and
will starting up with that front hip
cutter great execution
good job by yon framing that no doubt
good pitch so here's segura this will be
the 14th pitch of the at-bat for gene
segura out to center
robles is there
phillies had bases loaded nobody out
they stay ahead by three and harris wins
the battle harris just acknowledged
segura said that was a great at-bat
chase anderson facing trey turner to
lead the bottom of the sixth inning off
in the pitch is cracked a deep left
center field this one is crushed it's
way back and it is long gone
trey turner hits chase anderson's first
pitch
about seven rows deep into the brewhouse
red seats for home run number eight
and that breaks the shutout bid
of chase anderson here in the bottom of
the sixth it's the phillies three and
the nationals won see
you
later
trey turner two for three
his eighth of the year
and maybe there is a momentum shift
taking place
so that's it for chase anderson who was
cruising through five [ __ ] rod the
phillies right-hander who just came in
schwarber by the pitcher and by
everybody this is going to be a one-run
game
fantastic 11-pitch rbi at that for kyle
schwarber getting his 10th rbi
three to two schroeber doing a good job
getting on top of that 98 mile per hour
two seamer up and away
beat the shift monster
love to see it
come
his way into home plate
we got a ball game bob what a great at
bet by kyle schwarber yes we do my
friend it's a 3-2 game bases are loaded
two outs
alvarado gets ahead of the count on josh
bell one ball two strikes
swing and a miss he got him 101
and bell leaves him loaded here in the
seventh inning no runs one hit and three
men left thank goodness all right so
bone is up his responsibility is to get
the runner over to third pitch swung on
line to right there's a base hit towards
right center and this will get odouble
home and going sliding in the gap is
soto he's got it but boom thinking too
as well he's got himself a double and he
has given the phillies an insurance run
here in the eighth it's now four to two
phil's
so the bases are loaded for andrew knapp
with one out in the top of the eighth
inning
and the pitch is lined out to left field
in for base hit one run is in
here comes mccutchen the throw goes to
third a two run pinch hit single for
andrew knapp and the phillies lead it
six to two
seventh pitch of this
the short one
and the pitch
swag gonna miss he got him with the
split now hector can celebrate as the
ball game is over and the phillies take
game one of this three-game series they
do so by a final score
of six to two now they did get some
clutch base hits john finally in this
ball game which helped lead them to the
victory